[Music]
so
good morning it is seven o'clock and
this is sky news breakfast these are our
top stories this morning
three billion pounds of investment into
skills and education for what the
chancellor is calling a skills
revolution
accidentally shot on a movie set by a
prop gun we need help immediately
the
on alec 911 film set
roll up your sleeves more people are
urged to get vaccinated as a way out of
the pandemic as cheaper covert tests are
introduced for travellers
a new pilot scheme in the uk is to use
genome sequencing on a hundred thousand
newborn babies to detect rare diseases
a crisis on the buses with a shortage of
at least four thousand drivers
nationwide as staff leave to become
lorry drivers
the weather mild but windy with showers
for most but the southeast will be fine
into the evening
and at a quarter to eight we'll take a
look through the morning's papers with
writer benedict spence and broadcaster
gemma forte
good morning thanks very much for
joining us here on breakfast three
billion pounds is set to be pumped into
the education system for post 16 year
olds to boost skills for young people
entering the workforce chancellor rishi
sunak is expected to make the
announcement in wednesday's budget
there'll be new traineeships extra
classroom hours available and new cash
to revitalize existing colleges in what
mr sunak is calling a skills revolution
it's one of a raft of budget
announcements released by the treasury
overnight as our political correspondent
rob powell reports
skilling up to secure jobs 3 billion
pounds is expected in the budget to help
young people after they leave school and
those changing careers
last summer sky news spoke to chris from
lancashire after leaving his job just
before the first lockdown he was
struggling to find another we want to
work we will we'll do anything we're you
know it doesn't matter if we're stacking
shelves or if we're running companies
the jobs just aren't there at the moment
i got really really lucky after eight
months and 200 job applications chris
did eventually find a role but says
being able to reskill would have helped
him
i would have retrained i would have
reskilled
i said i would have done anything
to get back into the job market again
the first time in a very long time we
have more job vacancies than we have
people out of work
but again it's if everyone is trained to
be a farmer and you want a brain surgeon
because that vacancy is always going to
be there
it's people like chris that could be
helped through 3 billion pounds for
adult re-skilling as well as teenage
year courses and college revamps
elsewhere one and a half billion pounds
will be spent to help bring in overseas
investment and foreign talent
seven hundred million pounds will be
spent on the post-brexit border system
and a fleet of new maritime patrol
vessels and over 400 million pounds will
go on victims services crime prevention
and prosecutions
education leaders have welcomed the
skills cash but economists say the
tangible impact may be more limited most
of the extra funding for allied
education and skills spending is kind of
reversing some of the cuts and some of
the quite big cuts have happened to the
funding over the last decade and we've
seen for instance the government has
announced extra funding for adults to
get a level equivalent qualifications
which is funding that was already
available until about 10 years ago
the treasury has another tricky
balancing act to this budget on the one
hand sustain the nation's recovery and
make good on promises to level up on the
other a desire to manage the country's
finances responsibly and demonstrate
traditional conservative low tax
credentials and if that wasn't enough of
a challenge for the chancellor he also
has the other government department
spending to set
rishi sunak has said he'll do whatever
it takes to support families and ease
the cost of living over the coming
months but with many competing political
and economic pressures it's hard to
imagine that everyone will end up
getting what they want
rob powell sky news in westminster
well let's get more on that announcement
by the government of three billion
pounds into education as part of the
budget this week the money is expected
to be directed as we've heard towards
post 16 education as well as later in
life adult learning joining me now is
the chief executive and principal at
bridgewater and taunton further
education college andy berry andy good
morning to you
how mu where do you how and where do you
think this money should be spent
well um we've all seen um i've been
following following with great interest
the challenges in the supply chain
to to our shops and our supermarkets but
the businesses that i speak to are
really struggling to find appropriately
skilled people
to fill their vacancies so i think this
funding needs to be targeted as flexibly
as possible so that we as uh educational
organizations can work with employers
understand their needs understand their
vacancies and support your viewers
to secure the skills they need to secure
those jobs
the largest chunk of the money is going
to the post 16 16 to 19 year olds and an
aim to see a rapid escalation in the
numbers on t levels now for those who
haven't heard of them what is a t level
a t level is a fantastic new initiative
um we'll immediately understand what an
a level is well the t level is the
technical equivalent of an a level so
the same academic standard but
brilliantly uh t levels incorporate a
placement within an employer so you can
get that skills those experience along
with the knowledge at the same at the
same point but importantly at the same
um
standard as a uh an a level
so an example we've got for example
we've become the first fe college in the
country to deliver nursing degrees and
so our t-level students in health
get chance to spend some time within the
nhs
and then progress on to perhaps a degree
apprenticeship
there has been concern though has it
that t levels are coming at the expense
of the b techs which were described as
the engines of social mobility and that
some were going to lose out
yeah i think that's a really important
concern
t levels are you know like unlikely to
be right for every sector um of the
economy and so immediately my mind would
be uh
big industries uh around the creative
arts and performing arts and sport and
others it's probably less likely that
public emergency services would be
another great example you can imagine
it's much harder to get that placement
element so the b techs and applied
general qualifications still have a
really important role to play
but i think you know for the right
sectors in the right place the t levels
really help raise the standard of that
technical education
the coronavirus pandemic has changed the
employment landscape in this country
what about the focus on adults and
re-skilling being able to retrain for
for different careers
yeah i think it's essential really in
the sort of post-covid world as we begin
to build our economy back of course
let's not forget uh the implications of
brexit as well and the challenges that
brings this type of investment in skills
is absolutely essential for our economy
i think perhaps too often we think of
education i think of schools when we
think of skills and think of
universities well in fact the further
education colleges are kind of the
engine room of our economy and provide
access to those skills through your
local college
to enable adults in our communities to
get the skills they require
to secure that all important employment
how far does this money go then how big
a difference will it make andy
you know we've had a really tough few
years the austerity has bitten further
education
the sector really really hard
this money is so welcome it's amazing to
be on uh
sky breakfast this morning talking about
further education colleges you know um
so it will help begin to redress many
years of underfunding i mean what i'm
really interested to see this week as to
whether there'll be extra funds for 16
year olds to catch up it's really
important those
young people have been massively
affected by kovid 19 that when they come
to college we can support them to catch
up um
and uh you know again it's it's
important for um our adults but it's
just almost you know it's just a start
so i'll be watching really interestingly
the budget this week let's hope for much
more to follow and hope this is just an
initial sort of trail of the great news
for our skills and our further education
colleges this week
so a positive first step for you andy
berry thank you very much indeed for
joining us here on breakfast this
morning my pleasure
on the great debate tomorrow night we
will be discussing the cost of living
and asking what's got to give with
almost all aspects of life getting more
expensive and the chancellor set to
deliver his budget on wednesday we want
your stories and your questions for our
panel of experts email the great debate
at sky.uk to join our virtual audience
and tune in at 9pm tomorrow
and trevor phillips will be joined by
the chancellor rishi sunak this morning
he'll also be speaking to labour's
shadow chancellor rachel reeves and
professor adam finn who sits on the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunisation that is at 8 30 this
morning
the
from a member of the crew reporting the
shooting on the set of rust has been
released giving a sense of the panic and
confusion in the moments after it
happened even as the investigation into
the accident involving alec baldwin
continues other productions are already
changing the way they use guns real or
props our u.s correspondent greg milam
reports from los angeles
some of the finest moments in hollywood
history were captured at the bonanza
creek ranch it will now be forever
associated with one of the movie
industries most tragic we've had two
people accidentally shot on a movie set
by a prop gun we need help immediately
so was it loaded with a real bullet or
one
i cannot tell you that we now know a lot
more about the incident that led to the
death of cinematographer helena hutchins
killed by a single shot fired by the
actor alec baldwin he and the crew
member who'd handed him the gun unaware
it was loaded with live rounds
the armorer on set hannah gutierrez read
in a podcast after her last movie had
talked about the intensity of the job
it was also my first time being head
armored
as well
and how was that
you know i was really nervous about it
at first and i almost didn't take the
job because i wasn't sure if i was ready
but doing it like it went really
smoothly i think loading blanks was like
the scariest thing to me police say
their investigation continues no one has
been arrested or charged the tributes
continue for helena hutchins her husband
matt posting a photo of her with their
son she inspired us all with her passion
and vision he wrote her legacy is too
meaningful to encapsulate in words
those who worked with her wonder whether
her death will lead to prop guns being
banned on set today i'm saying yes i
mean there's there's an aesthetic
argument one can make about it um
whether or not it looks you know as good
but
today i think i i definitely feel like
i'm questioning those kinds of things
this is this has made me think very
differently well if you think you can
succeed where they fail already the
makers of this police drama have
responded by banning what they call live
guns from their set
from now on they'll use pellet guns and
special effects those who've spent their
career on set say that should be just
the start i hope that this will be an
agent for change because there's really
no reason there never should be someone
who dies making a film i think that
it'll definitely be looked at and there
are ways that you can mitigate the the
risk by doing it in post-production
by changing the shooting angle
at a vigil in new mexico helena hutchins
was remembered so too the impact of her
death
every person deserves to go to work with
complete security
knowing they can perform their work and
return home safely
this moment has shaken
all of us to the very core
there are still so many questions over
an incident that to many was unthinkable
one that's left an industry in shock and
a family grieving a loss they describe
as enormous greg milam sky news los
angeles
labor is urging the government to
immediately scrap vat on energy bills to
prevent the cost of living crisis
worsening this winter the party says
cutting v80 on domestic energy bills
from five percent to zero should come
into place as soon as november and
remain for six months
colombian armed forces have captured the
country's most wanted drug trafficker
darrow antonio usuga known by the alias
antonio is accused of killing police
officers and recruiting and sexually
abusing children the u.s government had
been offering a 5 million reward for his
capture colombia's president described
the arrest as the biggest blow to drug
trafficking in the country since the
death of pablo escobar in the 1990s
one of ecuador's most successful
athletes sprinter alex quinones has been
shot dead quinniness who was 32 was the
first ecuadorian to win a global medal
and a track event taking bronze in the
2019 world championships he was shot
dead in the street in the port city of
gaia quill
a breaking news this morning from
taiwan where a magnitude 6.2 earthquake
has struck in the northern region near
yelan the european mediterranean
seismological centre said the quake was
at a depth of 40 kilometers that is 25
miles we'll bring in more details as we
get them throughout the morning here
now from today fully vaccinated
travelers arriving in england from
non-redless countries will be able to
take a cheaper lateral flow test on or
before day two of their arrival instead
of the more expensive pcr tests it's
been described as a huge boost to the
travel industry so how does it work well
travelers must take a photo of their
test and booking reference which they'll
need to send back to the test provider
to verify the result passengers can also
pre-book a test to have on their arrival
at some airport testing centers
those who test positive will receive a
free pcr test to verify the result
however a 10-day hotel quarantine
remains in place for those seven red
list countries regardless of vaccination
status
meanwhile boris johnson has issued a
call to arms urging everyone to get
vaccinated against covert 19. it follows
rising infection levels and concerns
that new restrictions may have to be
introduced and less numbers go down the
health secretary sajid javid has said
cases could go up to a hundred thousand
a day but some experts are calling for
an immediate return to working from home
and the mandatory use of face masks
in his statement mr johnson says this is
a call to everyone whether you're
eligible for a booster haven't got round
to your second dose yet or your child is
eligible for a dose vaccines are safe
they save lives and they are our way out
of this pandemic
a new pilot scheme is to use genome
sequencing on a hundred thousand newborn
babies to detect rare diseases it's part
of a five billion pound package of
investment into projects to tackle the
uk's biggest health threats expected to
be announced in the budget elena
vassalinovich is in the newsroom for us
melina what can you tell us about this
plan well at the moment existing tests
can identify nine conditions but but as
part of this project and with new
technology doctors will be able to
detect over 200 rare diseases now
this could has the potential to save as
many as 3 000 babies a year and a genome
really is a complete map of a person's
genetic codes it contains lots of
valuable information about a person's
health so considering that genomics
england says that over 80 percent of all
severe and rare diseases contain a
genetic component when you have a
newborn genome sequenced it could enable
doctors to catch certain conditions
early and treat them early and it's
especially important with those where
treatment is actually more effective
before symptoms actually occur
now some of this five billion pound
investment will also be directed to
tackling health inequalities and in
particular to increase representation of
people from diverse backgrounds in
genomic research projects there'll be an
aim of recruiting
at least 15 percent of people from
ethnic minority backgrounds for these
types of projects and that is
particularly important to make sure that
they're not disadvantaged by not having
enough accurate information or uncertain
information about health conditions that
may plague them
elena thank you
there's a shortage of at least
000 bus and coach drivers in the country
with many companies blaming hgv bosses
for poaching their drivers the
situation's become so serious that
services are being cut and suspended in
many areas because there simply aren't
enough drivers to keep buses on the road
becky johnson reports
they're trying to keep things moving but
it's not always possible
this bus company in the east midlands
has lost 10 of its drivers and across
the country there's a shortage of more
than 4 000 bus drivers many tempted away
by big salaries on offer to drive hdvs
instead
the mindset of the bus drivers at the
moment is that over in the haulage
industry the employees threw money at
the problem at the shortage so the
mindset is now we might as well do it
for 20 pounds an hour driving a lorry i
was 10 pounds an hour driving a bus
a shortage of drivers means fewer buses
can run the cancellations a problem for
those with no other way to get around
i need two buses to run on time to get
to work yeah
it's quite inconvenient if my next bus
gets knocked off the service because i
go up and work at
a warehouse but i feel for the older
people who can't walk into town you
can't get
to the hospital
if you haven't got transport it's having
an impact on a daily basis at the moment
the bus companies know their customers
aren't happy
we can't compete with the logistics and
distribution sector at this moment in
time couldn't you just pay drivers more
it's difficult to do more than we have
because other cost pressures are also
going up so fuel for example is costing
us a hundred thousand pounds more so far
in 2021 than it did in 2020 because the
price of fuel is escalated
the department for transport say they're
working closely with the bus sector over
workforce issues
all passengers can do is wait worry and
wonder if they'll get where they need to
go becky johnson sky news derbyshire
good morning is a little it is a little
after half past seven you are watching
sky news breakfast an update now on the
breaking news we brought you earlier
from taiwan where a magnitude 6.5
earthquake has struck buildings shook in
taipei but there were no reports of
damage it could be felt across the
northern and eastern parts of taiwan
with the epicenter in yilan county
three billion pounds is set to be pumped
into the education system for post 16
year olds to boost skills for young
people entering the workforce there'll
be new traineeships extra classroom
hours available and new cash to
revitalize existing colleges in what the
chancellor rishi sunak calls a skills
revolution i'm joined now by jeff barton
general secretary of the association of
school and college leaders jeff barton
good morning to you
how big a skills revolution will this
allow to happen
well i think that's a good question time
will tell whether this is truly a
revolution but nevertheless we know that
post-16 education fe in particular from
independent sources has been since 2010
starved of funding so it's good to hear
the chancellor recognizing that if we're
genuinely going to do something around
this race leveling up then the need for
appropriate skills is going to be
particularly important i think it's a
bit of a gamble in one sense because i
think probably sarah if you were to say
to your viewers what do you know about t
levels
lots of them would find that's a harder
question than what do you know about a
levels what do you know about gcses what
do you know about apprenticeships for
example and the reason for that is that
t levels have only been in existence for
one year so no young person has yet got
a qualification called a t level and the
government just needs to be a bit
careful i think about overstating things
with an untried untested qualification
which ultimately is going to be down to
young people to think well do i want to
do that instead of something i'm more
familiar with a levels uh
btechs cambridge nationals
apprenticeships so it's not just about
the funding it's also about making sure
those courses are really doing what they
are promising to do yeah i mean i'll
admit i had to look up the detail of t
levels uh this morning and at the moment
there are only some 2000 students taking
them aren't there but this is going to
see it upscaled in a big way
that's the idea of it it's worth just
reminding ourselves that you've got
something like 900 000 young people who
are doing post-16 education one way or
another a third of those
we reckon are doing
btx so a btec allows you to do that
vocational qualification uh they're well
respected by employers and for a lot of
young people particularly in
disadvantaged communities they have been
a stepping stone for them then to go
into higher level apprenticeships or
into higher education degree courses and
the government at the same time is
talking about the new t levels which is
you say you've only got 1500 to 2 000
youngsters doing them at the same time
they talk about that they're also
talking about scrapping many of those b
techs they need to be careful about that
because with 300 000 young people doing
those p-techs they're going to feel cut
adrift and it's just worth saying this
sarah i think that until the age of 16
we have a curriculum that won't talk
about skills it talks only about
knowledge it says that certain subjects
are far more important than other ones
now if you're going to ask me as a 16
year old to choose a course that i might
not have heard of studying one subject
in the way that a levels and b takes
would allow me to have a range of
subjects and to do 45 days of work
experience if we can find the employers
who are going to provide that that's
quite a big ask and i think that one of
the things the government should be
looking at is making sure that we give
skills education more emphasis pre-16 so
you've got young people deciding i want
to do t levels because i've started to
have some of that technical experience
before i finally get my gcses and other
qualifications at age 16 if that makes
sense
and jeff i wonder before we leave you if
i can just ask you one thing about the
vaccine roll out for school age
children secondary school children it
has been reported today that the
education secretary nadim zahawi is
going to write directly to 12 to 15 year
olds urging them to get a covid vaccine
bypassing their parents
would you support this and would it help
give a boost to what has been a sluggish
rollout in this group so far
i certainly think just conveying to
young people directly why this matters
why you know one of the great
achievements of humanity in vaccinations
haven't they is a good idea that's not
to say that many of their parents aren't
absolutely supporting them and
ultimately will be giving consent so if
what that's about is increasing the
amplification of why this matters so be
it but i have to say sarah there's quite
a lot of young people who were queuing
up to have their vaccination you know
last week in school
and the team that was supposed to be
doing the vaccination either didn't turn
up or didn't have enough of the vaccine
we have to get this right because i
don't think it is just that there is a
reluctance
look at scotland for example 40 of young
people compared to our 12
in england i don't think this is just
about reluctance i think the logistics
have been frankly in too many cases not
all somewhat disappointing
okay jeff barton thanks very much indeed
for joining us thank you
175 cyclists are setting off from london
this morning their destination glasgow
and the cop 26 climate conference none
are professional cyclists but all are
passionate about climate change joining
me now is patrick new who's involved
with ride the change patrick morning to
you wow you've got quite a journey ahead
of you
yes indeed but it all starts here yeah
we delighted us all come together we had
a crowdfunded to see if the ride could
actually happen but we at possible do
nation in arab yeah put this out there
and there was massive interest and we
were sort of overwhelmed by the
enthusiasm for doing a ride in late
october up to glasgow but yeah there you
go 175
so 175 people cycling 475
miles what's the aim what are the goals
you want to achieve along the way
well it's a fun and social way to sort
of highlight the climate solutions that
are out there and inspire climate action
so for example everyone is not getting
sponsored to raise money but to raise
actions so they've gone out to their
mates using our platform by donation and
they've said to their mates rather than
give me a fiver why don't you pledge to
change your energy supplier or eat less
meat or pledge to not fly for a year so
literally we're aiming to do 5 000 of
these actions and you can highlight the
carbon saved um and hopefully it's yeah
it gets people talking so today we're
cycling to oxford they'll be talked in
the evening we'll have a lunch stop and
it's all about getting that peer-to-peer
impact and inspiring other people to
increase their climate action but also
to increase their like local councillors
and their local mps to increase theirs
it's interesting then so as we're
focusing on cop 26 and what global
leaders are or are not committing
actually what you're doing is looking at
what we can do as individuals to make a
difference
yeah it's clearly a bit of both i mean
we believe that it's all about making
this a mass movement and we want the
public to get involved and with the
public involved sort of politicians
corporate organizations will be forced
to take greater action so for us at
possible it's a bit of both it's
individual but it's also the sort of
systemic so who has gone involved what
kind of people are taking part then
patrick
good question you did highlight that we
are all amateur cyclists so yeah you hit
the nail on the head i mean there are
some days up to 90 miles but yeah it's a
group
we've got some that have been uh the
youth climate strikes we've got some
that work maybe in lego and
sustainability it's a a lot from the
corporate sector and sustainability but
a lot of just sort of you know really
keen people in that are ambassadors for
climate action in their communities
we've got a breadth of sort of people
from around the country um but yeah
they're all coming together but this is
it i don't i've not met you know not
many of these 175 so part of the ride is
finding out what different communities
are doing what different people in
different companies are doing you know
how they're creating and inspiring
greater action where they live so
one aim of the ride is for people to
yeah literally just sort of increase
this community and empower these sort of
sort of champions for climate action
yeah and hopefully empower your legs
along the way for that to ride at
patrick if people are watching this and
feeling inspired by what you've had to
say how can they get involved how can
they support what you're doing
yeah so if you go to um our social
handles we are possible.org um
and our obviously our ride deliverers
at donation.com and adventureuncover.com
there'll be information on the ride but
there's going to be a lot on socials
but if you go to we
arepossible.org you'll find information
there
patrick you thanks very much indeed and
the very best of luck to you and all of
those cyclists
cheers thanks a lot
welcome back to sky news breakfast hello
if you're just joining us we are going
to take a look through the sunday papers
now with the writer benedict spence and
broadcaster gemma forte uh morning again
uh to both of you at benedict we're
starting with the sunday telegraph uh
again another paper looking at uh what
the chancellor will be announcing in the
budget on wednesday billions of pounds
to digitize the nhs i sort of feel like
we've been here before
do you really surely not um it's uh yeah
this is the story that uh
5 billion is set to be allocated to uh
bringing nhs sort of records and online
systems up to speed after it was
revealed that there are some that still
uh work on paper systems uh but this is
actually just a drop in the ocean when
you consider that there's also gonna be
four billion allocated to building new
hospitals or hospital wings and up to 12
billion just to maintain hospital
facilities uh you add to that the 36
billion that's already been allocated uh
to sort of clear the backlogs that have
been caused not just as a result of
covert but in general in the health
service uh it's quite clear therefore
that you know it makes sense on the back
of a pandemic that you know the
healthcare service is going to be um
sort of at the forefront of the
government's agenda but the numbers that
are being talked about here are just
it's unsustainable is the problem and
the the the telegraph does also mention
that uh sajid javid the health secretary
has been tasked with massive overhaul of
the system uh one uh anonymous source
said that he had to get a grip of the
nhs and one can't help but agree
actually the population is aging it's
not getting any healthier and this is
just going to continue to be a massive
weight on the public purse and
ultimately we can't continue to keep
footing these bills especially i'm
afraid if the economy is going to be
sort of perpetually at risk of being
plunged into a deep freeze because of
you know all kinds of measures to curb
the spread of certain diseases
ultimately there does need to be reform
in the nhs we cannot just continue to
increase its budget infinitely which
ultimately means more taxes on other
walks of life well with the urgency of
what sahaja javid having to do as well
benedict because the the proceeds of the
health and social care levy going into
the nhs is a boost for now but the aim
is to get them into social care which we
know is desperately in need in the next
three years um let's turn to the
observer and many of the papers with uh
more reflections from the
asset
of russ the film
alec baldwin's film gemma
at which a crew member at the
cinematographer helena hutchins was
fatally shot and alarm bells were
ringing before this incident according
to the observer
that's right and this is one of those
stories i think when everybody first
heard about it that you just couldn't
possibly have ever imagined that you'd
be reading and yes that's correct
this piece in the observer does go into
more detail about how
there had been text messages from
various crew members saying that they
didn't feel particularly safe it had
been a production that seemed to be
mired in quite a lot of chaos there had
been some walkouts as well
and they were only days into a
three-week shoot when this absolute
tragedy occurred
um you can only imagine how traumatic it
must be for everybody concerned the joel
souza director has also been shot but of
course this this lady the the director
of photography only 42 years old you
know a mother a partner to somebody has
lost her life just at work doing her job
behind the camera so um i i immediately
thought why is there any necessity to
have any live ammunition on a film set
um apparently it's to make things more
authentic seems ridiculous to me and i'm
sure that going forward now the whole of
the film industry will be looking at
tightening all of this up so that it
never happens again yeah we're already
seeing evidence of of some uh programmes
changing their policies using pellet
guns special effects for example and we
heard that extraordinary podcast clip
from that the head armor on the set from
talking about her previous job it was
the first time she'd been in that role
and she wasn't sure
that she was qualified for it i know i
know and this is going to be played and
played it's very haunting in light of
what's happened and as you say she was
sort of saying that she didn't
necessarily feel experienced enough to
take on the role but she was going to
give it a go she came from a family
who'd been doing this as a job but of
course you listen to those words now in
light of what's happened and it's
horribly eerie and of course hindsight
is a wonderful thing but should she have
ever had that job in the first place
awful
um to the times benedict and it is
looking at cop 26
and uh what is to come and of course
whether xi jinping is going to play any
part at all
this is of course the key question
because without china getting on board
with the efforts to reach net zero uh
you might as well not bother frankly
given that china now burns half of the
world's coal um you know climate change
doesn't you know it it doesn't just
affect us in the west it affects china
as well a lot that's happening in sort
of global uh slowdown in supply chains
and the energy fuel cost crisis it has a
lot to do with china it's not
particularly dealing well with everybody
who pays any attention to it will know
what's going on in the the yangtze delta
and you know how much coal is uh costs
to burn in china right now but
one needs to remember ultimately that
the the communist party does not see
things necessarily through the lens of
what's best for humanity it sees things
through the lens of what's best for the
communist party for beijing and it will
look at net zero and the amount of money
that a lot of western nations are
spending on moving from it must be said
dirty but much more efficient energy
sources to much more expensive cleaner
and much less efficient energy sources
and it will see this as an opportunity
basically as another power grab to move
itself closer to the position of being
the global um
leader rather than second fiddle to the
united states or having to compete with
the eu it's also worth noting of course
that you know by doing this by not
looking to cut back too much on fossil
fuels it also drags countries that rely
on fossil fuel production closer into
its orbit so that's you know all of the
opec uh countries that's other countries
as well including russia that's
including a lot of you know sub-saharan
african countries
one needs to look at that i'm afraid in
terms of the broader sort of
geopolitical picture and see that
ultimately it's not necessarily in
china's short-term interest to sign up
for everything that the west is doing
and that is i'm afraid going to put it
at serious risk of not working
okay um to the independent
gemma the great half term getaway didn't
get off to a great start at heathrow
yesterday what happened
well um the words were uttered that i
certainly wouldn't want to hear when if
i was traveling
which was put essential items in your
hand luggage instead because your bags
may not arrive at their destination so
imagine that you've carefully packed
you've gone through all the admin
involved especially with traveling at
the moment and then chaos because they
had a technical issue at um terminal
five at heathrow so apparently absolute
chaos ensued and passengers were forced
to queue leave their luggage rummaging
through their bags trying to determine
what they definitely needed and what
they could stuff in their hand luggage i
i would absolutely hate this situation i
like taking lots of luggage and i would
be uh very stressed i think
um trying to determine underwear i don't
know shoes what do you take yeah what
are your essentials
as well it's always that awful moment as
well isn't it when you're at baggage
reclaim and you're waiting and waiting
and everyone else is disappearing and
then you realize there's no bags left
yours haven't made it
but at least people are being able to
get away now for half term to the times
uh benedict now and a story on bears
what is it
the times calls this a plague of bears
which you know in the grand pantheon of
our post-biblical plagues after covert
perhaps seems a little bit you know
dramatic but um i quite like this story
um it's in transylvania in romania large
bear-like creatures most likely bears
have wandered down from the hills and
are roaming through towns in search of
food or perhaps employment um supposedly
this stems from a 2016 ban in romania on
the hunting of bears on the shooting of
bears
and as a result uh the standard number
of calls to police for bear related
incidents in 2016 was about 200 a year
in the first six months of this year
there have been over one and a half
thousand incidents of people calling the
police on bears that have been found in
schools in restaurants in back gardens
there is a sad element to this as well
people have been killed by bears whilst
out for their morning runs and the issue
is now what is to be done because a lot
of local people are taking matters into
their own hands they're trying to trap
the bears they're trying to shoot the
bears they're trying to poison the bears
but you know romania transylvania the
carpathian mountains in particular has
europe's largest um population of bears
over 6 000 at the last count
and these are not necessarily the
easiest things to kill they're apex
predators they're 400 kilograms they
move at 30 miles an hour and they can
climb trees uh so you know
from out of the frying pan of covid and
into the fire of the bear plague i think
is the way to look at this and the quote
highlighted that stands out to me living
with bears in your house is not normal
uh suiting the obvious uh benedict and
gemma thank you both very much indeed
for taking us through some of the
stories in sunday's papers more coming
up next on sky news breakfast